you think for a second that maybe a
movie studio learned a tiny better
restraint and nope
[Music]
so apparently Sony is working on their
next spider-man related film now a quick
update on sort of all things spider-man
related we know about the next actual
spider-man movie come out it's going to
be comes it's going to be called
spider-man part from home it's featuring
two villains Mysterio and oh god I've
suddenly forgotten who the other one is
mecir is the big one that's gonna be
featured in that obviously we have into
the spider-verse coming out which may or
may not be directly connected since it
seems to be a multiverse story we'll see
we've got venom coming out later this
year they had in development silver and
black which was going to be a team-up
film between silver sable and black cat
- spider-man supporting characters that
has been taken off the schedule doesn't
mean the project's completely shelved
but it does mean that it's in a state
where it's not going to be ready by the
time they thought it was so it's either
completely dead or basically put on the
backburner and they had also previously
announced they were working on a Morbius
film who is a I I hesitate to call him a
Spider Man bill and that's how he was
originally introduced as a spider-man
that villain is even an overstep kind of
because he's a weird character but
antagonist certainly that and since Sony
had the rights to him they were looking
at doing him as a solo so this is all
very familiar to kind of what happened
or what was happening around the time
amazing spider-man 2 was supposed to
come out now it did seem like they were
showing a little more restraint than
that time because that one they had like
very blatantly announced we're doing a
sinister six movie working out they were
planning an Aunt May prequel movie which
they denied but then when the Sony hacks
came out we found out no they were they
were really talking about doing
and pretty much all that cut Shelb when
amazing spread him into underperformed
now this time while we already kind of
had shades of that it did seem like they
were approaching it a little bit more
cautiously like I said silver and black
getting moved off the schedule seemed to
be a good thing is like oh they realized
it's not gonna be ready cool
venom they've been trying to get a
better movie forever that's almost like
they had to get that monkey off their
back Morbius
while that was a slightly odd choice he
has carried his own series at a number
of points he can work as a solo
character that can work but now they've
also apparently started working on a
Kraven the hunter movie and now I'm
starting to get flashes too when they
really got over ambitious ahead of
amazing spider-man 2 and kind of what's
scary is they're doing it almost at the
same point in the whole thing which is
we're waiting on the sequel to the one
that did well and they're already
assuming massive success and planning
all these spin-offs so I guess a little
bit about Kraven the hunter first of all
Kraven the hunter is a longtime Spider
Man Bill and he is an iconic spider-man
villain and I would like to see Kraven
the hunter as a spider-man villain
actually he would have been my pick for
the second spider-man film if I'm being
completely honest second or third
definitely he's not a guy you start with
so Kraven most famously he's done a
number of things but he always been part
of the sinister sakes all this stuff but
most famously Kraven was a he was
obsessed with spider-man because he was
always kind of big about taking down
hard to get game that's what his name
you know means and implies and he has
some degree of power he's kind of
augmented a little bit the way Black
Panther is you know herbs and potions or
whatever
now most famously he beat spider-man
buried him alive stole his costume went
out at spider-man defeated a villain
that had that spider-man hadn't been
able to defeat and then feeling that he
had accomplished everything he wanted to
accomplish killed himself
that was Cravens last hunt was that
storyline that is what he is most famous
for doing so here's the problem with
doing a Kraven solo film especially
since it appears to be that they are
gearing up to do it the same way they're
doing the venom solo film now I've
talked before about how introducing
venom absent of spider-man is a bit of a
weird thing because a big part of
Venom's deal is his hatred of spider-man
not the shared hatred between both Eddie
Brock and the symbiote but that's being
removed now that said you can remove
that and still have a interesting story
in a compelling character especially if
you're willing to go AR and horror
tinged with it because you've still got
a story of a guy possessed by an alien
parasite and you know struggling with it
trying to come to terms with it and
trying to be good ish in a very violent
way you can still get a movie out of
that certainly now what where it's gonna
become weird is if they ever actually
try and use him as a spider-man villain
I'm not sure how they're gonna justify
that because spider-man isn't part of
his origin now but taking him as a
character unto himself yeah you could do
that that works craven craven isn't
interesting outside of his stories
dealing with spider-man I mean that's
that's why he never held a solo title at
least so far as I know I mean maybe had
a one shot or a mini here there but he's
not a guy with his own story to tell
he's he's very much a supporting player
in that way he needs spider-man in his
obsession toward spider-man to work
although I mean his stuff with Squirrel
Girl was cool too but again he was
already established with the spider-man
stuff before that could even work so the
idea of doing a Kraven the hunter solo
movie like why
why would anyone be interested in that
and the other thing is Craven Wow a
decent name for spider-man fans that's
not a name that more casual fans really
know and certainly they don't think that
much of because as well known within the
comic book reading community as Cravens
last hunt is because of how dark that
story is it hasn't really been adapted
to you know the TV shows or and or any
of the other media and I do think how
dark that story is is a big part of why
Craven has not turned up in the movies
up to this point so he's not a guy he's
not like venom where venom has his own
titles in comic book stores venom had
already appeared in a in a spider-man
film not one that a lot of people liked
but it gave a level of awareness he's
appeared in pretty much every in garden
in incarnation of Spider Man that's been
done as a TV show as a cartoon so
there's plenty of groundwork laid you
know for people just casual things going
oh yeah I kind of remember that crave
and they're gonna be like wow like it
reeks of just overreaching and like I
said Morbius made more sense to me
because again he's a guy with a story
that is interesting completely separate
from his relationship with spider-man
because he he becomes a vampire not
through supernatural means but through
science and a bit like venom he is a he
is a killer but he is trying to sort of
aim his homicidal tendencies at bad
people so there is there is still a
story to be to be told they're
completely independent of spider-man but
Cravens history absent spider-man just
isn't that interesting so the fact that
they're planning this and who knows how
far they are and it could just be
planning but it just
Sony's desperation is palpable I I've
talked about sort of Sony's general
status as a movie studio before they
really really are desperate for a stable
franchise because most studios at this
point have at least two reliable stable
franchises the things that they can go
back to the things that are the sure
thing that allow them to also do other
stuff Sony kind of has spider-man and
they have to share that playground with
Marvel and so far as we know they it's
not actually a profit share situation
but they don't have complete control
over that process I'm at least not spite
in the movies with spider-man himself so
they're they're grasping at straws and
that's exactly what it looks like and
that's what it feels like in this level
of desperation just makes me very very
nervous because spider-man the
spider-man films proper at least for the
first one anyway
we'll see with the second one feel more
built it homecoming felt built as a
story to tell
not as a platform to launch a franchise
it had the potential to launch a
franchise of course but it didn't feel
like it was dying to design does that
first with a story retrofit into it
amazing spider-man 2 ultimately the
reason that movie was had great moments
but was such a mess is because it felt
like a PowerPoint presentation for
investors saying here's how we're laying
out the next 10 years worth the
spider-man movies were gonna make with
like weird awkward connecting bits
between the between these little bits
that they're showing is like n here's
the part where we introduced the
sinister six and here's all the things
and you know here's and here's how we're
gonna get the Green Goblin and here's
this and here's that and here's the
Rhino and his and and then they
connected it really weakly and loosely
that's what spider-man amazing
spider-man 2 felt like
and I just really I don't have a lot of
faith in Sony as a studio then I'm a
pretty cynical person when it comes to
my thoughts on how Studios are run and
why they make the decisions that they do
I will say however there are some that
do what they do well Marvel certainly
does honestly you know Fox is going to
become part of Disney now but Fox had
gotten its its feet under itself in
terms of managing things like x-men and
seems to seem to have ditched some of
its more egregious habits in recent
years you know you've got some studios
that seem to have a sense of things
Warner Brothers they know how to get
movies made but it you can you you can
really feel these the executive hands so
you got overreach there and and but Sony
just feels like they're floundering as a
studio they feel like they are drowning
and desperately sping for air and they
are hoping that this spider-man stuff is
a lifeline and the sad thing is if
managed well it could be but they may
very well be making the same mistake
Warner Brothers did in regards to the DC
films the mistake that they are still
trying to work themselves out of and be
sure they don't fall into again which is
to plan their next five or so years
worth of tentpole films based off
something that they don't know if
anybody wants yet because they seem to
be assuming that Venom's gonna be a hit
and they're moving forward with more
movies about spider-man villains and
that is presumptive and it's too early
like it's one
people may not want people may not like
venom we could totally have an amazing
spider-man 2 situation where they lay
all these groundwork on all these plans
and then the movie does fine or god
forbid even flops and then they're gonna
look at all these plans and go crap
which is exactly what happened to the DC
EU after Justice League or bommie even
before that but definitely Justice
League was the nail in the coffin to the
approach they've been doing up to that
point of all this big interconnected set
up and set everything up based off this
film here's the next five years worth
the stuff we're gonna do plot and now DC
is very deliberately gone look we're
slowing down we only have dates
announced for the ones that are actively
in production we're working on a Batman
we're working on a birds of prey we're
not even announcing years that we're
planning to release those because we'll
figure it out as we move along because
we're not gonna presume that everything
is a hit which was a smart thing for
them to start doing and I think Sony
despite their own history plus what
happened at Warner Brothers their
desperation is overriding whatever good
sense should be telling them this is a
bad idea on how to proceed so that's it
I mean that that start has sort of my
pick me apart wide the idea of Kraven
the hunter movie isn't a good idea in
the first place and then just launched
into an overall bleak outlook on Sony
hadn't planned on it going there but
there you go
so Kraven the hunter what Sony's up to
in general in regards to Spider Man
spin-off material what do you think
about it whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it there's all the stuff to
do you know what it is you don't need me
to tell you I will mention that I do
have a patreon but there's a link to
that and a ton of other stuff it's in
the description so until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]